Bartlett personnel from USD and he's
talking about something detecting object
metal recent natural scenes requires
inside a torus cell-cell interactions
well I would thank the organizers I am
one okay I'm going to be talking about
the work of Gabriel Mel Ramachandra who
well maybe graduated five years ago or
so again apples been kind of taking the
lead on this yes we're related actually
gave her where are you Gables he's
hiding well Gabriel is now a graduate
student at Stanford and neuroscience and
some of his professors are here and I
think he drove up to make sure that I
would give him full credit for this I
try to steal okay and actually as a
human interest story my father is also
here so that Gabriel's grandfather
emeritus professor of biophysics and my
sister even came down there I'm sorry
felt like I was a kid at a track meet
and the whole family came to Keane okay
okay so the can't meet a comment
yesterday about two kinds of people and
two kinds of projects among people who
like to use models one of them being the
type who who take complicated datasets
and try to sort them out confusing
incompatible paradoxical results and
build a simple model that's parsimonious
that explains the data and and then the
other type being ones where who are
willing to kind of make fools of
themselves and try to suppose what a
neural circuit is doing and then study
the tasks that that neuron is or that
circuit is facing in the world to try to
understand what the task is how how to
solve it well you know what the
difficulties are and how you might
engineer a solution to that task using
pieces that look like what the brain has
available and thus try to build a system
that might be isomorphic you hope to the
actual neural system and then you could
you know maybe make correspondences so
this is a talk that's definitely met in
that second vein so I mean the
difference to a traditional who talk is
that I meant to spend kind of like Bruno
did a lot of time talking about the
problem and we stand and we spent a long
time studying this problem faced by the
nervous system in order to try to get
ideas about about how to solve the
problem
so this has to do with well object
recognition is sort of a high-level
thing if I say to you what is this
object here what would you say good and
this one so how do you know that's a
gorilla he's got his paws on the ground
well I didn't mean how did you know it's
not a macaque I'm just I'm just saying
the the way that we answered this
question and the reason that artists
draw these kinds of pictures is that the
key information for object recognition
for this kind of classification problem
he's sort of lies in the boundaries of
the objects the the contours that
describe the object I've got a nice
demonstration from Irv Biederman maybe
some of you've seen this before so I'm
gonna start a little movie here and then
I want you to tell me when you see a
fire hydrant okay fire hydrant
good it gets good okay so stop this
thing now the that is an illustration of
the fact of the power of contours the
two to evoke the object category inside
your brain and so contour is what our
contours contours are really
orientations at positions that's what
the information contained in contours is
and so since we're so good at object
recognition it was it is pleasing to to
discover and it wasn't us who discovered
it was Hubel and Wiesel who discovered
this back in the early 60s that the
first processing stage in the visual
cortex seems to report the position and
orientation of object boundaries we've
seen already you know in a couple of
talks that the cells in v1 we all know
are tuned to orientation of course in
position so they would have a receptive
field looking for say bright here and
dark here and an oriented axis and so
this might be and Hubel and Wiesel
certainly said it and and umpteen other
people have said it since that these
would be the elements that would be the
first level of computation of the
contours that would eventually let us
recognize objects now the one of the
quandary is that you run into almost
immediately is that if you take a
conventional model of a simple cell it's
actually a very poor boundary detector
in natural images I'm going to show you
that quantitatively later but we made
this slide last night actually to kind
of illustrate this conventional model of
a simple cells that you have kind of a
linear filter with positive coefficients
and negative coefficients so that would
be like like you know this basically
that's kind of what that is intended to
signify and then that thing goes into
some kind of divisive normalization so
really from a simple point of view could
think of this is sort of adding up the
top row minus the bottom row the pixel
values and then dividing by the top plus
the bottom it's kind of a surrogate for
a simple cell model now the problem with
this is is that that if you applied that
this operation this filter in this
device of normalization to these three
pictures you would get the identical
result and and I think you'll agree this
is this is really a high probability
contour and then who knows what this
even is and and this doesn't look like a
contour at all and you have to yield the
same response in a simple
so a simple cell is not a good
discriminator of shape and and this is
frustrating because that's what it's
supposed to be doing so this is this
this leads us to the problem well what
exactly do you need to do in a natural
image well these are natural images this
is a toy demonstration nonetheless I
think I'm kind of striking but what do
you need to do in a natural image in
order to decide whether there's a
boundary of an object at a given
location what is the actual problem look
like so we came at this problem with you
know with with great vigor to try to
figure this out so if I were to show you
this picture and ask you if there's a
contour running through this what we
call a reference location this dash box
kind of in one end and out the other
would you say yes I think you would
agree there is and here you you would
say no and so if you wanted a computer
program or a brain to answer this
question automatically or to see the
contours that are there and not see the
ones that are not there what does the
computation look like now you're not you
shouldn't feel that you're at the brain
or any machine that would be trying to
solve this problem is limited to having
one kind of simple cell like receptive
field overlapping with the location
where you're asking the question and you
can only rely on that one value we know
that in the cortex in a small area there
would be perhaps hundreds or thousands
of cells whose receptive fields overlap
with the position of that location where
you want to know the answer and why
can't you take advantage of all of them
somehow why should you not be able to do
that and maybe you could perform much
more a much more have a much better
shape discriminator than you could with
any individual Sun and so what what we
did was we we asked well we followed we
basically use Bayes rule to tell us how
we would use all of the filters in the
neighborhood of a place where we want to
know whether there's a boundary what
would Bayes rules tell us is the way to
combine the information from all of
these nearby cells in order to get the
answer so the probability that yes
there's a boundary given simple cell one
simple cell two simple cell three these
these guys is all over covering the
neighborhood and there could be hundreds
of these and so this this this is
basically a rewrite of Bayes rule and
I'm point out the form of this it's just
it
the form where it says it's 1 over 1
plus e to the something or other and
that's that's a sigmoid and it's that
the something-or-other is the sum of
terms and so a thing that can compute a
sigmoid on top of a sum of things well
that's what people think a conventional
neuron model in the neural network is if
you add a bunch of things up and then
you run it through a sigmoid so that's
the form of this calculation under the
assumption there's an assumption here
which I can if it bothers any of you we
can come back to it later so the
question is what is it that you should
be adding up and putting into a sigmoid
in order to solve this problem according
to Bayes rule so here's a neuron that
has a receptive field that is sort of
the one that's right overlapping with
where we're asking the question here's
the neuron is receptive field as you
know we sort of off to the side and up
and miss oriented and here's another one
and and the point is that these the
things that we should be adding up
when this neuron fires his firing rate
should go through this function this is
a function of his firing rate and the
function could look something like this
as this firing rate increases then what
you want to add up is this value as a
function of f1 and here's a value as a
function of f2 and here's the thing as a
function of f3 that's what these that's
a cartoon of what these things look like
now which is which is a little bit weird
because normally when we think of a cell
affecting another cell that's trying to
decide if there's a boundary and it's
adding something up we usually think of
the cell attaching through it let's say
an excitatory connection in which case
this guy's firing rate as it increases
would increasingly excited to sound like
that and then the function would just be
going up and continue to go up or
inhibiting and it might go down and
continue to go down so we we what what
are these funny-looking functions that
we might that were ending up with well
the nice thing about natural images is
that we can go to them and collect this
data which is to say what does filter1
do when there is a boundary and what
does filter1 do when there's not a
boundary and filter 2 and filter 3
collect the data and actually evaluate
these functions and see what messages
these simple cells should be sending to
a boundary cell or that's that's the
that was the goal and here's an example
of collecting that data so this is the
this is some filter which has got an
orientation that would be centered here
at the at the question place the
reference location but a little bit off
oriented and if we collect the value
that of that filter applied in many many
natural images thousands of natural
images where there are boundaries
crossing through here that's the red
data and where there are no boundaries
that's the blue data clearly they're
different which means this cell responds
differently when there's a boundary and
not a boundary which is good meaning it
can help tell well this is a boundary or
not and so that's the these likelihood
these likelihood functions on and off
boundaries for this cell and we can do
the same thing for by the way when this
cell hat is when there is a boundary
here this cell tends to have a value
that's away from zero it has a positive
value why well it's kind of aligned with
the boundary and so it will be
overlapping with it and get stimulated
by it
whereas when there is no boundary its
responses are much closer to zero on
average this cell which is exactly miss
oriented for the boundary when there is
a boundary this cell tends to respond
almost zero so it's very clustered
around zero why because it's being it's
not being activated well by a horizontal
boundary thank you for asking that what
what this is this picture this picture
literally tells you the value of that
filter moving to the right of the of the
of the origin and if you were to flip
the polarity you'd be moving to the left
of the origin so that's these are
polarized as you can see this is sort of
the light dark boundary but then filters
but also your boundaries that you and
your images have a label of polarity
otherwise you could do that yes they do
well every boundary has a polarity so
there's no well you don't know that I
mean you know the polarity by by the
polarity it comes out of this okay yeah
yes
well the the way that we pose the
problem you could pose as their boundary
somewhere in the world or we can say is
there a boundary running through this
box that's the question that we're at
but correct in other words because you
think of a simple cell that has an
orientation as being sort of a dumb way
to you know a dumb way to get some
evidence about whether there's a
boundary of that at that location
without orientation yes a simple cell is
a an orientation well so the way that we
asked the question was the way that you
would think to ask it if you thought a
simple cell was doing boundary detection
and that it would be detecting a
boundary at a location of its location
and its orientation so we have the know
where the question is oriented so this
data set that you're looking at here is
is it sort of you can think of it as
that as an I so normalized data set as
if there's a normalization a divisive
normalization algorithm that is
operating in the background so that's to
sort of simplify the picture let me just
show you I mean I mean this is only to
say that we can collect the data at all
orientations and then and then a
different sort of shifts up above the
the the place of interest this reference
location and you know we just get a
bunch of different data data here oh and
now I wanted to go back here and I'll
just say remember that the thing that we
wanted these are the likelihoods we want
those colored terms two slides ago that
we were trying to evaluate those
funny-looking functions are gotten by
taking the ratio of the red to the blue
meaning you know places where you have
where the response when you're on a
boundary tends to be larger than the
response when you're off a boundary if
you see a large response you figure I'm
probably on a boundary that's the way
that that information can be helpful if
you take the ratio of those two curves
and you take the log of that now you end
up with these log likelihood ratios and
I have to move through these
informations again and you get these
functions so if we go back to this one
where we had the red in the blue what
this tells us says is as this filters
value goes up then it then the evidence
for there being a boundary that it
should send to the bow
to resell is just evermore positive as
its value goes up now this cell over
here as its value becomes more and more
positive than its evidence that it cents
to the bound yourself should be ever
more negative in other words inhibitory
purely but there are many cells such as
this one here which has the kind of a
mixed sort of evidence where at first up
to a certain value of firing of its
firing rate essentially it sort of sends
positive evidence and then if it starts
to fire even more it starts to turn turn
around to become negative evidence
here's another great example of that so
we have a lot of these non monotonic
essentially functional interconnections
between the simple cell precursor and
this putative boundary cell that would
be listening to the simple cell and so
this is this this kind of thing works
like it's excitatory this kind of thing
looks like it's inhibitory but these
things look like they're mixed and this
if you're wondering what incited to
romantic was supposed to represent a
mixture of that now here's the whole
data set that we collected and you can
see that this is now we just sort of
added shifts horizontal shifts and group
them together in groups of five and so
you can see there's this very that
there's a spectrum of interactions that
are called for by this if you want to
solve this problem using simple cells as
the inputs and and and you know it's
it's got some sophistical interactions
between the cells that are being asked
for but they still fall into a family of
things that kind of range from things
that go up monotonically or go down
monotonically or have an upside-down U
shape that's what we saw now how do you
get okay it's easy to see how you get
excitation you just send some excitatory
synapses over to the guy it's easy to
see how you get in addition how do you
get these non monotonic effects where
one neuron you kind of excited a guy
more and more but as you fire more you
start inhibiting this it's a little bit
like length tuning or some of these
other non monotonicity that you get in
the cortex so we we thought that the
most obvious candidate for the local
circuit motif that could allow you to do
all of these kite types of interactions
is this one this comes from Massimo's
paper and it's basically that whenever
you're in the cortex and you look at one
cell and then you look at how it affects
another cell it's almost always the case
that
both directly excites it and then it
inhibits it indirectly through an
inhibitory interneuron or two or you
know and there's there's a more
complicated versions of this circuit but
this type of if you imagine that the
excitation depending on which one is
more powerful which of these you know
how these the parameters of the circuit
are tailored that you can get pure
excitatory effects pure inhibitory
effects or effects where the excitation
kicks in at first and then the
inhibition overwhelms it and turns the
effect around okay so that's something
that this type of circuit we
hypothesized could produce and here's
just another way of saying it that you
could have a pure excitatory effect on
it on a downstream cell you can have a
pure inhibitory effect where you just
hit an inner neuron and you send no
direct excitation or you could have this
mixed inside it sorry kind of effect
through by both exciting and inhibiting
simultaneously so we asked well okay you
know if we if we just did a simple
conceptual model for increasing the
effect of the excitation with with one
curve and increasing the inhibition with
another curve could we reproduce this
type of data and the answer is yet so
let me show you the actual thing so you
know for this type of okay now I'm out
so like this guy here is you what you
have from this excitatory curve that
turns up and then they inhibit or curve
kicks on later and that's what brings
you up and then back down again so by
kind of very very simple conceptual
model having an excitatory signal and
then an inhibitory segment and just
adding them together you can already you
know in this kind of very abstract in
citation
scenario you can you can you can
represent the entire spectrum of these
cell-cell interactions that we measured
including the non monotonic ones which
is pleasing and but if you look at the
sigmoids
you know that you'd kind of collected
them all together here if by the way it
doesn't matter at all almost well how
you choose the parameters of these kinds
of sigmoids this type of fitting works
very very easily but no matter how you
do it you're gonna collect you're gonna
find you have a variety of excitatory
segments the different scale the
different threshold may different gain
so somehow you you have to
account for well how are you going to
get all of these different sigmoids just
conveniently there where you need them
in order to achieve these sort of
tailored effects and and you know what
sigmoid do you need and so can we leave
the dirty work of sort of creating these
these interactions as needed but to a
learning rule rather than having us just
come up with a corny you know the hand
waving simple model so the answer to
that question is yes the earning rule
can do the dirty work and what we should
what we have here is here's here's some
simple sell Preet you know presynaptic
partner that's communicating to a
boundary sell and all that we did here
was we simply made a bunch of variations
of it with different input out but
different output nonlinearities so they
all have the same receptive field but
some have different thresholds and some
have different gains so we kind of
represented the natural diversity that
you would expect among a population of
actual neurons and we did the same for
each each of each surrounding neighbor
so just imagine there's a small
population of simple cells covering
every location with different with
varying thresholds gains and so on and
then we used a one layer learning rule
this is no deep network it is a one
layer learning rule with because we're
the coefficients were learned onto an
inhibitory interneuron which summed up
all the inhibitory effects but these are
plastic weights and then these are
plastic weights onto the boundary cell
and just use the one layer Delta rule to
train with our edge boundary data that
that a stimulus picture that would come
in and activate all these filters either
was or was not a boundary and that would
train this neuron and these weights
would be learned what got learned so the
these colored curves are what got
learned and they they might at first
glance look reminiscent of the curves
that we just simply did by God by
measuring collecting data from images
human label dividing histograms and
producing log likelihood ratios what was
learned in the sense that the way that
this cell influenced the boundary cell
we kind of we teased the part with the
the independent effect of this one cell
was was the was these curves which look
reminiscent to the ones that the Bayes
rule tells you you should collect and in
fact the dashed line is the one that was
on the previous slide that was the one
that Bayes rule told you that you should
collect assuming in
we're learning just on a binary yes/no
if they're a boundary there yes so it's
a really simple learning situation and
but you know in many cases what got
learned these interactions got learned
were what were what what the
optimization to do do a good job at
distinguishing the boundaries shows a
slightly different curve than maybe what
the Bayes Bayes rule said but we
expected that because these filters are
not actually independent of each other
which is was an assumption the Bayes
rule makes and so we would expect that
the learning rule would try to
compensate for the non independence of
the different filters in choosing how
they would affect you know how these
connections would be how they would be
learned so anyway we so so basically the
point is it's a trivial learning problem
I'm almost done but the other nice thing
about this kind of approach which which
I value is that we can you know we made
this little model that says okay we have
the circuit I showed you a couple slides
ago and it's it's a bunch of connections
and they're learned how well does it
actually do to solve the problem that we
said we were trying to solve so how how
well does it detect boundaries this this
detector so this is kind of a fun graph
to look at one way to a good way to
quantify how well you do in a in a
classification task especially when you
have rare targets so edges and
boundaries are very rare in natural
images so if you just said no all the
time you'd be right like 98% of the time
and you wouldn't want to just say oh I'm
right 98% of the time because you
hundred percent of the time you say no I
don't see a boundary that would be done
so we do you trade-off recall which is
how many of the actual boundaries that
are shown to the classifier are caught
and are classified as yes they're
they're boundaries that's where you want
to be you want to be you want to catch a
hundred percent of them and then when
you say yeah yeah I see a boundary here
you want to be right 100 percent of the
time you don't want to say yeah there's
a boundary and then 80 percent of the
time it isn't so you want to be appear
at 100 percent precision so this is
where you would really like to be this
is what a simple cell like the justiça
generic model of a simple subtle that's
a linear filter within a normalization
does and it's very far away from from
this corner the rest of these curves are
just different variations of these
simple learning models with like ten
simple cell variants
like the one I showed you on the
previous slide is this purple curve but
you could make a hundred variants of the
cell doesn't improve anything so but
anyway if we look at the the performance
increase this is you know if we just
pick a number like eighty percent recall
then a single simple cell will have
precision about thirty percent means
that 70 percent of the time a simple
cell says yeah there's a boundary here
if there isn't and whereas this
combination of where the cell the
boundary cell is gets to listen to a
bunch of simple cells through these
through these inside Ettore certain
local circuits the precision is
significantly increased I mean it's
still not perfect by any means but this
is still a very simple model but anyway
it's it's significantly increased from
something like you know twenty five or
six percent or something up to around
fifty percent precision so there's a
there's a definite gain made by by
exploiting this type of circuit local
circuit motif so here's what we did just
the summer to remind you we we assumed
this is the assumption that we kind of
go you know go out on a limb and say
this we believe that these are their
boundaries it's detecting cells in v1 we
assumed that they receive input from
conventional simple cells not not that's
that's also an assumption then we
collected contour statistics and asked
Bayes rule to tell us how these dumb
cells should have influenced the smart
cells what the interaction function
should be we found that the interactions
have a spectrum of cases ranging from
pure excitation pure inhibition to these
non monotonic effects we showed that the
entire set of those effects can be
produced by this insight Ettore circuit
motif which is known to exist in v1 and
then we showed that that those
parameters can be easily learned with
the simplest type of learning
architecture that you can conceive of
and we showed that it improved the
performance significantly over not doing
it basically so I would conclude by
saying you know we can't I mean I you
know one is tempted to generalize from
what we learned but the fact is that the
circuit that circuit motif which is all
over the cortex allows for the
functional interactions between cells to
be much richer not to be limited to the
way that we think about conventional
neural networks as having excited to
learn inhibitory
interconnections between units but it's
it's it's quite useful to think about
the the connections between units as
needing to have higher dimensionality
and the actual functions of activity
level as opposed to just scalars of
times than activity level and so we
think that it's possible that it's not
just in contour detection that these
types of non monotonic and and this
variety of interactions is needed but
probably in many difficult
discrimination tasks we have reason to
believe that that would be the same type
of computation that would be needed and
so it's it's it's worth keeping in mind
that maybe want to generalize the idea
of a synaptic weight to the idea of a of
a of an inside Ettore you know family of
interaction functions that are possible
final comment I would say you know we're
talking about like what now if let's say
we blundered on the right solution and
this is really what the connections
between cell pair you know these are the
cell pair specific connections in the
cortex we are predicting should have
these very specific forms and let's say
let's say it's accidentally correct
because we you know we got lucky and we
mailed it I think if you look at this
you can kind of get the sense of how
difficult it would be to figure this out
if you didn't like come at it by
assuming the task I mean if you actually
went and started measuring things and
then you'd say oh yeah there's some
excitation inhibition would be really
really hard to collect enough data and
then if you did collect it you wouldn't
really know what it meant necessarily so
this is a really we think it's it this
gives us a feeling of security to to
come at it with a with it with an
expectation based based on assuming what
the task is and that would be difficult
to do it if we if you weren't willing to
assume what the task well that's it so
[Applause]
[Music]
we do have ideas about how you could
have unsupervised but but I did but yes
that is onyx that is an unexplained
aspect of this but there are you know
motion there are many ways that very
inexpensive ways of getting boundaries
from motion and so on that we think
could could provide the supervision but
we did not show that but I have faith
that that will that that could work okay
first question is we don't know where
boundary cells are or if they exist
remember how we came out this we said
let's say they do exist how would they
compute themselves based on cells that
we kind of know we're there and so we
would assume I mean the the ingredients
for doing this all exist in d1 so and
and also a boundary cell if you just hit
it with gratings and things that's going
to look like a simple cell it's gonna be
orientation tuned to location tuned and
and so on so they could easily be mixed
into the population we don't know so we
that's a critical thing to start is to
develop stimulant that kindig-it
distinguish between simple cells and
boundary cells and we have we know how
to do this so that's point number one
yes and point number two is we could
we've changed all kinds of things about
the precursor cells and the same basic
story exists there they're the same
types of the interaction families exist
we have sort of monotonic excitatory
things and monotonic and hit Vettori
things and then lots of of non monotonic
interactions so it doesn't nothing
fundamental changes if you make
different assumptions about what the
precursor cells are they're scale they
lose their length gas spec ratio
anything like that I mean but it will
change a little bit as you would have
must but it's not it doesn't like change
the way that we would tell the story as
far as we know yes
how could you expect well so we're
worked we're working with Jamie maser at
the University of Montana we're trying
to develop natural stimuli student will
structure natural stimulants to tease
apart this exact issue you know take a
little while to talk about how to do
that but I put it this way boundary a
simple cells should be sensitive to kind
of contrast but a boundary cells should
not care about contrast and be sensitive
to boundary probability which is a very
different thing you can have a very high
probability boundary that's low contrast
and you can have a high contrast thing
that is very low boundary probability so
they're they're dissociative Bowl and so
we can create stimuli that have all
different combinations of all of those
things and try to tease apart simple
cells from boundary cells and what we
expect is we're not gonna find
categorical things like there oh these
are perfect simple all diseases perfect
we would expect to find some kind of a
mushy spread like you do wherever you
look in the brain about anything yeah
these non-monotonic responses imply that
there might be some sensitivity to gain
modulation in the inputs because you
might be in some kind you might be the
monotonically increasing part in another
one you might be in a monotonically
decreasing part and so this could also
mean that there is some sensitivity to
contrast all those very are some forms
of normalization in the cortex with my
tail so is this a concern I don't get
the concern and by the way these
non-monotonic are not non monotonic
activities it's non monotonic effect of
increasing activity so when the activity
of the cell goes up gradually its effect
on its target can you become can be
excitatory and then later at a higher
rate inhibitory so it's not a non
monotonic activity rate from the start
the rate is higher than you might be the
regime where it's going down yeah well
yeah but so this isn't a dynamical thing
it's just a statement if at every level
of activity at you the presynaptic cell
what should your effect be on the
postsynaptic guy and that curve can be
non monotonic
which is which is unusual for the way we
think about it mean
interesting but it seems like it's in
the wrong shape you wouldn't well you
want what you'd ideally have if you have
a really a classifier goes up like this
and it goes really close to that upper
right-hand corner yes yes we can we've
worked yes sort of a separate thing that
we're doing is we've actually got a
we've done a lot farther this is sort of
a scientific thing that we've actually
worked on the engineering problem much
much harder and sort of we're like up
about here but I that's not really the
point of this talk but yes that's a good
question what's missing what is it what
is it is it's a testament to is that
boundary detection natural images is
extremely difficult it is so when you go
when you start going down into the
pixels we look there you just it's just
I mean I can't even put it into words
it is so messy that you eat like you
just go is it here oh he's there is it I
mean you just can't even tell what
you're looking at practically when you
look down the Picts device and you ask
you're asking a cell with a small
receptive field or even a local little
population to do a really good job it's
difficult so it's hard to get up in that
right hand corner you need a lot of
hardware much more than I showed you
what's this question
well okay actually let me let me let me
tie this what bernabéu said we're is
pointing out the benefit of kind of
exploding small numbers of cells in the
big numbers of cells to accrue benefits
do you notice in that little network
that I showed you that did the learning
we took each cell and we made like lots
of copies of it with different
properties this is what's V one is also
one of the kind of the you know gradual
paradigm shifts over time has been that
cells in v1 are very variable in their
they have interest even yack has got you
know papers showing all the very
building the receptive field properties
so we're kind of alluding to that and
saying there's a lot of very building
there and it just makes it to learning
much easier so yes is it an expansion
recoding into variable units that makes
the learning of this well I disagree
with what you just said if you were to
blur an image so there was no contours
left then you would not be a way that
yourself makes mistake yourself can make
a mistake said there's no boundary but
the human can still realize though
that's the dog with fire and even just
move out a little bit not
well okay so the assertion that this
would make a mistake in a human would
not well this graph exactly quantifies
that because this this is was it is a
very good with human ground truth this
tells you exactly how well that that
thing is gonna do and it's certainly not
anything close to perfect I don't want
to argue that the performance is great
of this little network that I'm showing
for as a demonstration thing I just want
to make the point that it's way above
using one cell it is all's you know that
I kind of cast as a little bit of a
paradox why would one simple cells a
really bad boundary detector okay but
then this is better and so therefore
there would be pressure for the cortex
to discover or to take advantage of what
it could take advantage of which is to
combine the inputs of many cells through
these sort of local circuits that are
learn about and do better but what does
the brain trying to do it's trying to do
that we're kind of over time so maybe we
should take it to lunch and come back to
and thanks